[Music]
it is seven o'clock this is a sky news
special programme on ukraine
well here in levitt missiles have struck
and destroyed a building near the
airport which the government says were
launched from the black sea
in moscow president putin hails a
special operation in ukraine while
celebrating the anniversary of crimea's
annexation
the way our guys are acting during this
military operation shoulder to shoulder
they help each other they support each
other but when it's necessary they cover
each other like a brother with their
bodies on the battlefield
a city reduced to rubble president
zielinski says russian forces continue
to block humanitarian corridors to mario
pole
three weeks on we'll have a report from
the city of kharkiv one of the first
places to come under bombardment from
the russian attacks
more than three million refugees have
now left the country as boris johnson
praises the people in the uk taking in
families in need
147 000 people and families across the
uk
opened their homes to the evacuees
and i'll be speaking live to a family
due to arrive in the uk soon along with
the host family taking them in
[Music]
well good evening from la viv in the
west of ukraine this city was plunged
into the war today ukraine's military
said cruise missiles were used in an
attack on an aircraft repair plant but
as the fighting continued here in moscow
vladimir putin attended a huge rally
with his supporters on the anniversary
of the annexation of crimea and praised
the heroic effort in ukraine well coming
up on this special program we'll bring
you the stories of devastation in the
capital kiev as russian forces continue
to launch their attacks as well as these
stories of people trying to escape to
neighboring countries and to the uk
but first ukraine's military said
missiles were today fired from the
direction of the black sea towards the
western city of lev hitting the state
aircraft
repair plant only a short distance from
the international airport here
skies alastair
just before 6 30 in the morning four
cruise missiles fired from the black sea
hit an aircraft repair facility on the
edge of the city
again russian forces have shown they can
and will strike deep into ukraine
nowhere now is safe or off limits
we can smell the smoke in the air but
this is as close as we can get with
probably 4 500 meters away
police the security are really on edge
this morning they are stopping every
single car that is heading towards
the airport complex there is a feeling
that this is the second time the
russians have been successful in
airstrikes around the vive
and there is a worry
that there could be russian saboteurs
russian agents operating inside lev and
helping out moscow
people here had been expecting the
russians to attack the airport so many
weren't all that surprised when it
actually happened
we have a bomb shelter next door an old
soviet one this lady tells me so we will
work work and keep working everything
will be fine we are preparing for
victory
that's the sort of defiance that
president putin is struggling against in
moscow today he emerged from the
security of the kremlin to address a
vast crowd marking the 2014 annexation
of the crimea it is the first time he's
been seen in public since the invasion
began
our guys are fighting are acting during
this military operation shoulder to
shoulder
they help each other they
support each other and when it's
necessary
they cover
each other like
a brother with their own bodies on the
battlefield
these images of russian nationalism and
seeming devotion to their president are
for a domestic audience but also
designed to show the world he is not a
leader on the run
putin has staked everything on this war
defeat is unthinkable for him with
chilling determination he finished his
speech by quoting the patron saint of
russia's nuclear fleet in all his
wonderful career he didn't lose one
battle he said once
so these storms
will glorify russia it happened then
and
today it's also so and this will be so
forever thank you
the mood here in ukraine couldn't be
more contrasting
even skripnick was killed when his base
was hit by russian airstrikes over the
weekend
his comrades mourn with the grim
realization that it could be them next
they are running out of space in the
city's military cemetery
the earth mounds of fresh graves are
marked by temporary crosses and the
portraits of the men who now lie beneath
the soil that they died defending
the pain of a mother's loss echoes
across this country
the feeling of pride for a fallen
soldier competes with stunned
bewilderment and anger
so much anger that is somehow come to
this
well as russia praised the operation
here in ukraine and the heroic effort of
his troops sky news has witnessed
civilians being hit from the ground and
the air near to kiev
six buildings including a preschool were
damaged in the attack in the city's
poddle neighborhood yesterday just north
of the city center and about one and a
half miles from the government quarter
holding the presidential palace our
special correspondent alex crawford sent
this report
this is what the russian authorities
insist is not happening the russian
leader is adamant his military is not
hitting homes in the ukrainian capital
or elsewhere because attacking civilians
is an international war crime and
president putin insists he's doing
everything he can to preserve the lives
of civilians
that's in direct contradiction to the
evidence we and many others are finding
on the ground
in the center is a playground around it
are residential blocks people's homes
schools
they've been pretty much reduced to
rubble
and these are some of those who used to
live in them they've lost everything
it's not human to do this she says
to attack the children
i didn't
they grab whatever they can in plastic
bags
pets tvs this is all they have now
right next door there are two schools
one is a kindergarten schools have been
suspended for the time being in the
capital or these classrooms would have
been full of pupils
[Applause]
these attacks are killing and they're
not soldiers or fighters this was an
elderly man one of many who felt too
frail to leave the city despite the
dangers
the daily attacks have left others badly
hurt
he survived with terrible head wounds
his wife did not
the victims here don't have much faith
in any peace talk succeeding and no one
we spoke to had any doubt about who the
attacks are aimed at
and you think it was specifically
targeted at civilians like you
yes yes i definitely think this she says
putin's trying to kill as many
ukrainians as he can
and the kiev mayor is absolutely certain
these repeated attacks on civilians are
ruthlessly executed
do you think there's any mistake this
could have been a mistake or was this
deliberately targeting civilians uh okay
if we're talking about mistake
his mistake
last
morning was a mistake 24 hours ago two
days ago was mistake huge mistake
destroyed the harketh and mario
how many mistakes they do it how many
cities have to killed and after that to
explain about mistake
from from russian forces
the uns warned the country's food supply
system is falling apart they were
scrambling to save stocks here a number
of these shops have been hit as well and
impacted and that is the worry that a
lot of these food supply chains bakeries
food factories have all been impacted as
well and they're being specifically
targeted
so they're wasting no time pooling
supplies in kiev these are all donations
they're trying to make sure those left
homeless and hungry by the bombings are
somehow looked after and this despite
worries that food warehouses in the
country are running low those who have
are giving to those who don't i think
that we are the second trump
on this country because the army is the
first one volunteers and it was
second
this is true community whilst the
capital may so far have been spared a
major assault among the workers here
there are those who've also lost their
homes to the daily bombings like tatiana
back two days later helping those she
feels are less fortunate it's strange
it's like something unbelievable it's
like from the movie something from the
movie came in my real life she showed us
her flat now in bits she's moved in with
friends for me i don't think
that i can die or something like this
i'm afraid
i i think
what i can do for
other people
and
somebody's right
how i can help
no because i'm lucky and in my building
about 400 apartments
and everybody alive
and other
i know other people not so lucky
the suffering is unrelenting and whilst
heave defenses are so far holding the
capital's residents are still bracing
themselves for more of this and worse
alex crawford sky news
well in new york the united nations
security council has been meeting at the
request of russia to discuss its
allegations that biological weapons were
being made in ukraine the russian
representative vasily nabenzia suggested
scientists in ukraine have been carrying
out experiments
as part of the flu fly away project the
harkov institute of veterinary medicine
studied wild birds as a vector to
transmit avian flu at the same time they
assess the ways in which the
transmission process could become
uncontrollable
cause economic damage and create a risk
to food security
show the involvement of the hark of
institute
in the work to
collect strains of avian flu viruses
which are have high epidemiological
potential and could cross the species
barrier
the russian ministry of defense also has
more and more new documents about the
transfer of samples of blood serum of
ukrainian citizens to the territory of
third countries including to the uk
georgia and germany
but the u.s ambassador linda thomas
greenfield dismissed his allegations and
also described russia's calling of
today's meeting as a potential false
flag effort in action
last week we heard from the russian
representative a tirade of bizarre
conspiracy theories
this week
we're hearing a whole lot more where
that came from things that sound like
they were forwarded to him on a chain
email from some dark corner of the
internet
president biden has a word
for this kind of talk
malarkey as i said one week ago ukraine
does not have a biological weapons
program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories
not near russia's border not anywhere
they're only public health facilities
proudly and i say proudly supported and
recognized by the u.s government
the world health organization and other
governments and
international institutions
well u.s president joe biden and china's
xi jinping held a two-hour phone call
today as the white house look to deter
beijing from providing economic or
military assistance to russia
well martha kellner joins us now live
from washington dc and martha we're told
joe biden was candid and direct so do we
know what was said
yeah that phone call ended around 11 a.m
local time here it took around four
hours for us to hear what the white
house perspective was on how that
conversation went what progress if any
was made i think from the vagueness of
the readout and that is their
interpretation of how this call went i
think it's fair to say that there were
no breakthroughs from this phone call
but rather this was
the beginning of a longer conversation
and a number of phone calls that the
white house hopes will happen between
president biden and president xi of
china they last spoke in november so
it's been a fair while and certainly um
you know much has changed in that time
i'll just read you a little bit of what
the white house have said the headline
was that president biden described to
president xi the implications and
consequences if china provides material
support to russia as it conducts brutal
attacks against ukrainian cities and
civilians this is the major fear u.s
intelligence suggests they say that
china may be willing to militarily
assist russia in their offensive in
ukraine russia's operation on the ground
clearly not going as well as they may
have hoped and anticipated the u.s fear
that china could intervene by supplying
russia with with cutting-edge air
defense systems or certainly
surveillance systems as well so
i'm told by a senior administration
official in a briefing that that was the
overwhelming focus of this call to make
clear the implications of this crisis
for the international order and the
overwhelming international condemnation
of russia
i'm also told that president biden
relayed concerns we were hearing the the
u.s ambassador to the u.n linda thomas
greenfield referred to those earlier
about russia possibly spreading false
information about chemical weapons held
in ukraine which could give russia a a
pretext a false reason if you like to
attack but we're told that that talk
between president biden and president xi
was direct and substantive as well
i think the white house recognizes that
if any world leader is going to hold
sway over president putin it is
president xi because of the close
economic ties that those countries have
and the overwhelming um power and
strength of china i think they recognize
that he is the person who could possibly
have vladimir putin's ear so that phone
call lasted around two hours it finished
four hours ago we'll hear later on today
from president biden's press secretary
jen sackey who may be able to provide
further details on how that call went
martha updating us there from washington
thank you
well as we've heard new missile attacks
have been carried out here in the west
of the country let's get some analysis
of the latest situation on the ground
wilfred frost is at the screen
for further analysis i'm joined now by
dr alex walmsley defense analyst and
fellow
at rusi uh alex good to see you uh in
terms of the latest we continue to see
the shelling in mario paul which we'll
come to
and in kiev but we wanted to start on
that attack in lev
last night of course far to the west of
the country uh on an airport there in
particular the military repair section
of the airport alex therefore felt like
a very targeted attack was it and where
did it start from given it's so far from
russian territory
indeed with this does seem to have been
a targeted attack on a piece of
ukraine's critical national
infrastructure and it seems to have been
the product of a cruise missile cruise
missiles have a very extensive range so
it's quite likely it could have come
from fired from a ship in the black sea
or from land
all the way over the russian border to
the east of ukraine
and of course uh poland is just there 45
miles to the uh further to the west of
lev where various nato forces
are housed let's uh move from the west
into the east and in particular dive in
to the dombass region we also learned in
the last 24 hours of russian attempts to
establish a no-fly zone in the donbass
region what would be the significance of
that if they did establish it
this appears to be a propaganda move by
the russians taking a proactive approach
uh by um trying to impose a no-fly zone
but as neither ukraine nor russia have
complete control of ukrainian airspace
this does seem to be a sort of political
propaganda gesture this week we also
learned of 800 million dollars worth of
military aid coming from the u.s how
much of a game changer could that be for
ukrainian forces
every piece of military hardware that
gets to the ukrainian forces is a game
changer they have shown in these last
four weeks that despite being
overmatched by the russian army they are
able to hold their own in some cases
counter-attack and even advance uh and
just finally we want to dive in uh on
mario paul which sadly uh seems to be
the epicenter uh of the war in this the
the fourth uh week under heavy shelling
despite that still in ukrainian hands
could it change hands sadly in in the
weeks ahead and how significant would
that be for russia
mario polo is clearly a strategic aim
for the russians because it's the last
city that sits between them and
the the peninsula of the crimea which
would give them a land corridor uh from
the russian mainland to the peninsula
but it is a city of some 400 000 people
it's been subjected to um
random mass dumb bombing um and the the
city is being pulverized it could take
many days still to fall but there won't
be much left of it if it does dr alex
warmsley thank you so much
well more than three million people have
now fled ukraine since the start of the
russian invasion three weeks ago that is
according to the united nations refugee
agency which says almost two million
have found sanctuary in neighboring
poland but the growing refugee crisis
has prompted concerns about the
safeguarding of the most vulnerable
people trying to escape the war lisa
holland reports now from the polish
capital warsaw
the refugees left ukraine in freezing
conditions some now need different
clothes others have nothing
yulia says guards on the train made them
leave their suitcases behind so more
people could be crammed into the
carriages
i really need these shoes she says i
wouldn't have to take charity if it
wasn't for the war
there's no shortage of things being
donated but three weeks after russia's
invasion and it's not just clothes toys
and food that the refugees need
there's an accommodation crisis the
polls are even planning to turn a former
complex used by russian diplomats into
emergency housing
prices are rising and terry from essex
is worried about where his family will
stay his workmates had a whip round to
help fund his flight so he could be
reunited with his ukrainian wife and son
now waiting for their travel documents
if i don't get it by friday then um i'm
strapped for cash for hotels
i have got people i can call in uk and
they can try to get some money emergency
money together
but i'm not that type of person
sisters anastasia and lubov are moving
hotels after the price of theirs doubled
overnight as a child lubov fled from
crimea when it was invaded by the
russians now just turned 18 her sister
has come from london to help her get a
visa and is worried about her safety
that's why i'm staying here with her
right now because there is no way i'm
leaving my 18 years old sister in warsaw
for hell knows how long
three million refugees have crossed into
neighboring countries but there are
reports of women and children going
missing prompting calls for more to be
done to safeguard them who do you now
trust
who's actually offering you the right
service who's actually offering you the
right support it is such a worry it's
great that people have opened up their
homes around the world but how do we
know that those are really in really
good intentions
this is the fastest growing flow of
refugees in europe since world war ii
now the authorities are trying to keep
up with the good will and support
desperately needed by so many driven
from their homes lisa holland sky news
warsaw
we'll stay with us coming up on this
special programme on the war in ukraine
shocking images revealed the scale of
the devastation in the city of mariupol
in ukraine south which continues to be
the target of heavy fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
nice to see you again mr barney
why meeting you
[Music]
[Applause]
well welcome back to live in western
ukraine
new vision out today shows the scale of
damage in mariupol a city that has been
hit hard by russian attacks since the
start of the war well in the south of
the country it has come under heavy fire
skies nick martin has the latest
this isn't a military target it's what's
left of the shopping mall in the city of
mariopol
ripped apart by russia's insatiable
desire to destroy
on the ground you can see how the
windows have been blown out how the
metal has twisted and it's hard to
imagine that just a month ago this was a
busy place full of life
at the last count more than 130 people
have been rescued from a shelter under a
theater bombed by russian shells but
hundreds are still missing under the
rubble the russians deny they were
responsible
can you hear me
yeah i see you
petro andreashenko is an adviser to the
mayor of mariopol what is the situation
with supplies of aid first aid medicines
food water for those who are trapped in
the city it's terrible we haven't
anything you know we haven't water for
our people we're having medicine we
haven't food we haven't anything and we
can help for our people because it's
really it's absolutely blocked for our
for russian troops
three
hundred thousand
people in mariupol now
the life is being drained from mario
paul as each brutal day passes
this used to be a swimming pool
windows and doors blown out
debris everywhere
the russian military see this as making
gains
in mario units of the donetsk people's
republic with the support of the russian
armed forces are closing the
encirclement and are fighting against
nationalists in the city centre
here a row of shops apartment blocks
scorched trees
damaged roads
evidence of heavy attacks
it's thought that more than three
thousand people have died in this city
ivan galtvenko managed to escape with
his life and he helped around 400 other
people do the same
what is happening now is like seeing
your relative dying in your hands you
see as their organs stop working one by
one their eyes getting dark while you
hold them in your hands
mario paul is a city completely
surrounded now
and there's a cold brutality to the
russian tactics here
and that is to destroy everything
raising mario paul to the ground
and crushing the will of its people
nick martin sky news ukraine
well let's take you to the white house
press secretary jen sackey now it does
recommend fourth doses for the
immuno-compromised well it hasn't been
of course as you noted approved for
others and they're running a vigorous
data-driven process and right now over
100 million americans
have been boosted millions more have not
done so and are eligible to do so and
need to get boosted but to go to your
question yes she had been talking about
ukraine and has switched to kovid
as you can see well do stay with us
coming up on this special program on the
war in ukraine uh we will talk to a
couple who are fleeing ukraine and a
family in yorkshire who would like to
host them back with all of them in just
a moment
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well welcome back to levi if you're
watching sky news our top stories then
this evening russia has attacked the
city of lev in western ukraine which had
largely escaped the fighting one person
has died and dozens have been injured in
the capital kiev
there are fears that more than a
thousand people are still trapped under
the rubble of a theater which had been
sheltering people in the city of
mariupol
and russia's vladimir putin has appeared
at a public rally in moscow celebrating
the annexation of crimea
[Music]
well so far 4 000 visas have been
granted to ukrainian refugees wanting to
come to the uk with thousands of
families due to welcome people into
their homes in a moment i'll be speaking
to one of those families as well as
refugees too from moldova but first
ashton harinag reports on the people
desperately trying to make it to the uk
draped in the colours of a country under
attack wren's home in cambridge is ready
to welcome a ukrainian refugee but it
wasn't a difficult decision to make
katrina also happens to be her best
friend i was three years old when there
was a beirut war
and i
we narrowly escaped death at that wall
my dad saw a rocket pass by our window
and if it had taken a slightly different
trajectory i i wouldn't be here
britons who know the name of a ukrainian
person they wish to host can now fill
out an application but even with
passport details and relevant
documentation as ren found out it's
still not without its challenges when do
you plan to arrive in the uk enter the
date in this format well that would be
nice if uh if she knew bless her when
she could arrive details few would know
when fleeing war
like niara and her daughter eleonora who
fled harkev
they've been sleeping rough but have
found a family in hampshire willing to
take them in
she knows plenty though who are still
stuck in limbo right now it's very
important to match to find uh the people
in ukraine who really needs any help
it's strange for me to ask for that for
help but right now we really need that
help for prospective hosts without a
personal connection it's a more
uncertain way
friends introduced fiona to her match
she hopes to welcome olga and her
children as soon as she can i feel now
very pleased that i have by various
roots found you know a connection and
and we seem to have
linked up with someone who a family who
who we could provide accommodation to so
it's been it's been a tricky you know it
hasn't been easy to find that
route so far 4 000 visas have been
granted to ukrainians with a relative in
the uk that's in addition to those
opening their homes out of goodwill some
say the process is too bureaucratic is
the uk doing enough i think the uk can
do so much more one of the things that
wouldn't really enable that would be to
lower um the barriers to be able to find
safety in the uk by getting rid of the
visa restrictions and making people
enabling people to be able to come
directly to the uk rather than having to
apply before coming
that would enable people to be able to
come here far faster those fleeing have
had their homes ripped from them and
rebuilding their lives will rely on
support hundreds of thousands want to
help and their first challenge is to get
them here
ashley harinag sky news
well let's find out more then about the
practicalities of sponsoring people from
ukraine we can talk to two couples on
both sides of the process so i'm joined
now by sabrina edge and her daughter
kitty who are in drift field in
yorkshire and by lilia and vitali malone
who have fled ukraine are now in moldava
and are hoping to join the edge family
well welcome to all of you sabrina let's
um let's kick off with your side of it
then shall we why did you feel compelled
to try and help
um well it's not the first time we've
been on a scheme like this and we were
with positive housing in action in 2016.
so it's always as a family being an idea
for us we've got a spare room um
and we just were watching the news with
the break out of the war and we just
felt compelled that we had to you know
offer
two rooms that we have
and this was
nearly three weeks ago um so you know it
was before the government had even
announced any scheme any incentive
nothing like that it was just purely on
a we need to help we've got the
availability let's do something
wow so you got there before the
government uh fascinating well let's go
to lilia
in moldova and you've obviously managed
to get out of ukraine so tell us your
story then where were you and why did
you decide to flee
yeah
one morning we woke up with uh such bad
news yes uh and i can say that
uh why it was
unexpectable because it was a very early
morning yes we were preparing to take
our kids to school and we are preparing
to get
to our place workplace i mean and you
know my
aunt called me in the morning and said
you know
wake up quickly because it's gonna be
dangerous today to stay at home because
i could see some worse sorry some
rockets in the sky over my house and she
lives 120 kilometers away from us
and it was like an evidence i mean that
um
it's a very close person called me and
she said me if i saw something maybe
online i wouldn't believe
and i was starting
crying because i didn't know what
exactly to do and then we heard this
alarm syringes and to tell the truth the
basements were not ready to
uh for
accepting people i mean they were
wet and dirty so we couldn't stay there
for long there wasn't any water and so
on and we were really scared i didn't
know what to do my children were crying
i was crying too my husband tried to
support but
uh we decided to we leave just a not far
away from moldova so that we decided to
to leave this place to go to abroad
because it would we decided it would be
better for our family to stay there
so so why the uk perhaps you could ask
your husband vitaly how he feels about
going to the united kingdom
he is very glad that we have such
opportunity to change something yes in
our life because we can't see any future
here especially for our two daughters
they are still young yes they are
they're not ready for such like like
with war i mean that we want to protect
them first of all
and um
[Music]
of course he's a little bit worried
because he can't speak english very well
but uh as i i speak english very well so
it was my decision to go to the
english-speaking country first and we
were thinking which one to choose and we
found this family and to tell the truth
they their support made us to go to uk
well that that's lovely isn't it and
sabrina then so how did that sort of
connection part of it happen because
that's been confusing a lot of people
how you get matched up with another
family
well we were lucky my daughter my eldest
daughter um sent a facebook group um
that she'd seen and i think two weeks
ago there was a couple of hundred people
on it and think now is like 50 000
people on it and there was a um
i t guys that developed a website in 24
hours um from madrid and i found them
put in my details lilia did that
two weeks ago today um and she sent me a
message on the 4th of march an email
saying you know could we have a chat we
spoke and you know that's what we've
been doing ever since a lot of face
times a lot tour around the house and
all of us have just got this real nice
friendship that's you know sort of
naturally
bloomed and we've all got similar
interests the girls have got a whatsapp
group with their eldest daughter
victoria um so we're just desperate we
did the application today it took three
hours
um and we're still no further forward on
a date so we can't plan they can't plan
it's just
you know
stressful
so lilia what are you holding up and
tell us about your children and how they
feel how old are they and how do they
feel about coming um what what is quite
a distance from ukraine to be fair
yeah um uh these are my our four
passports yeah uh because we i worked
with them i mean that we changed the
information sabrina sent me her copies
of the password i sent her our
information so
uh we had a hectic day but luckily we uh
completed the application online and um
yeah we have two more daughters um
is 14 and ilona is only six
unfortunately they went to sleep because
they were tired today yes they're also
worried
about moving to other countries because
sometimes they say oh we want to come
back home but unfortunately i don't know
how to say that we can't back come back
all the things are there
and they sometimes want to take
some toys and they say unfortunately we
can't take all of them so i mean that
yeah we are very lucky i can say so and
i hope a lot of families will be as
as lucky as we are yes they will be able
to apply unfortunately uh not all
ukrainians speak english yes and the
website is not in in russian or in
ukrainian and this is a problem yes
because only
i could apply myself but um usual people
for them it's really difficult to apply
because everything is in english
i did see one thing actually that the
home secretary put out in ukrainian so
hopefully that will be changing um but
kitty i wonder if i could um speak to
you i don't know how you how old you are
how close you are in age to victoria as
well and how you feel about having you
know effectively more children in the
house
um
well
i'm 11
and
i don't feel like
uncomfortable with them coming like
i've spoke to them on like a what's up
group and like we've got to know each
other
so like
we've done lots of face time yeah
you're comfortable you come yeah yeah
well i'm sure it's going to be amazing
um it's going to be interesting
certainly for you and all the other
families who want to join one final
thought from uh from you uh lilia and
vitali obviously you know you're
desperate to to move as soon as you can
um but will you always look back at
ukraine and watch the pictures of what's
happening in your country with sadness
and of course the hope to return there
yeah of course we are going to fall yes
and of course we have such feelings that
we we don't need to leave our country
yes and there is like a pain in my heart
that they have to do it unfortunately
yes because of this all these bad circle
circumstances yes and um sometimes i
think oh should they really do it or
maybe i should do something but i i
understand that we have to do it because
it's really becomes really dangerous for
example there was a rocket along the
river which we are live near yeah i can
see the rivers through the window there
was a rocket flying to vinitza yes and
it was destroyed in the air it it turned
just
next to our town to vinitza to them and
you know it's becoming more and more
dangerous to stay here
best to keep your children safe isn't it
um we really appreciate you all joining
us we wish you the very best of luck uh
lilia and vitali malone and i'm sure
there'll be english lessons for for all
the people who can't speak english and
also sabrina and kitty edge
well done to both of you and fingers
crossed you get to move soon thank you
very much indeed
i do the same i've got a notebook in my
hand how lovely anyway coming up on this
special program on the war in ukraine we
will talk about the situation facing
civilians
here with a u.s under secretary for
democracy and human rights from the u.s
[Music]
[Music]
government is confirming that they are
now engaged with russia's soldiers air
raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center oh
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
well earlier i was at an arts center
turned makeshift aid center here in
levitt to see what the humanitarian
situation was on the ground here
well we know that many parts of ukraine
are desperately in need of provisions
like food this is where they will be
distributed as you can see this is uh
oats many of the signs are actually in
english our understanding is this lot
came from germany and in fact national
governments may well donate stuff that
ends up here bags of flour as well these
sacs will be sorted out here and
different
parts of ukraine will put requests in
and the provisions will be distributed
down they have about 250 vehicles
leaving per day to go to other parts of
ukraine camouflage netting as you can
see this will be going to troops as well
and drinks provisions food and in fact
here we found a michael who's from
actually from south end on sea are you
not you should be managing a hotel right
now why have you decided to come here
i just couldn't sit at home and just um
watch what's going on around the world
here over here
to help help so how long have you
actually been here i've been here for
about five days now and how long will
you stay i'm not sure it's not really
sure yet was it complicated for you to
come and get in here and and be able to
do this um not really actually
because i flew into poland into zest
south sesoff
sorry polish people sorry
and then
took a train
all the way to live and then i came in
here i went to the army base first
they drove me here and i signed up
got a band and i started unloading
trucks loading trucks up
loading all this stuff up and
just helping out as much as i can so
what was it about the images that you
saw from ukraine that drove you to want
to come here in fact the innocent people
the children
just just being stranded losing
everything having having to lose
everything and start all over again
is a painful thing to watch
just houses getting destroyed buildings
hospitals it's just just not right
yes and michael j paul there just like
sabrina edge that we spoke to in
yorkshire driven to do something to help
the people here having watched the
pictures and read about the devastation
uh here in ukraine and certainly that
center deals with about a thousand
refugees a day sometimes up to fifteen
hundred who come with almost nothing
just the shoes on their feet and they
get restocked with food festival as well
but also clothing
warm gear for the kids like socks and
hats also bedding you know they pack up
all the duvets so if you've donated a
material or you've paid into a charity
possibly as well it may well be that the
stuff you've donated ends up there
people drive stuff to the polish border
it's then brought across the border and
ends up to be distributed to the
refugees here but also out into the
wider communities
to those who are displaced across
ukraine
now the uk prime minister has said he
thinks vladimir putin sees himself as
the successor to stalin and the russian
czars in an interview for fyi sky's news
program for young people boris johnson
was also asked if he would consider
taking ukrainian refugees into downing
street the prime minister was answering
questions put forward by readers of the
children's newspaper first news
a lot of people think that president
putin is a very bad person what did you
think of him when you met him
i think that he is a
guy who
grew up in the
the cold war he's a
secret service man he's a kgb man he's a
russian spy that's how he thinks uh he
thinks in a very adversarial way towards
the west he believes that the west
countries like ours are trying to
encircle russia and threaten russia and
he's obsessed with that idea
and he's wrong
i think he he sees himself as being the
successor in a way not just of stalin
but of the sars
and he sees himself as a
somebody in in the tradition of an
all-powerful russian autocrat that
that's how he sees himself do you feel
bad that the uk hasn't taken in more
refugees when you know some places like
poland and neighboring countries have
taken in close to two million
they have but of course the the uk
doesn't have a a border so we haven't
received the first wave but we are
taking many many more now as they as
people decide to come on to to the uk
and that's right you know we've got an
amazing record as a country for taking
people in well following on for that
will you be housing any refugees here
well i i am not the uh i'm i'm a mere
i'm a mere uh
tenant
of this i'm not even a tenant i'm a i
don't i don't know what my status is
exactly i'm i'm the temporary occupant
of this uh
of this place
um it is up to
uh to to others to decide how that would
work if we could do it then i'm sure uh
people would welcome it i'm sure that
i'm sure there are a lot of people here
who
would want to do it
and you can see the full interview with
boris johnson on fyi this weekend on sky
news and also on sky kids
well the uk chief of defense
intelligence lieutenant general jim
hockenhall has given his latest briefing
and it is grim reading i have to say for
places like mario paul the latest
pictures as you can see utterly
devastating
lieutenant general hockenhall said that
russian operations have changed the
russia is now pursuing a strategy of
attrition this will involve the reckless
and indiscriminate use of firepower this
will result in increased civilian
casualties and the destruction of
ukrainian infrastructure and that is
certainly what we have seen
the latest also from the united nations
makes grim reading 2 they say that
quarter million people have now fled
ukraine but a big jump up in those
numbers who are internally displaced six
and a half million people now internally
displaced that means upwards of 10
million people have had their lives
upended so far by this conflict
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you